[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
we're taking a closer look at the moment
following the deadly rush shooting my
understanding um
you were you were in the room when the
lady went i was assaulted
but first the defamation suit of johnny
depp versus amber heard ms heard was
uncooperative she wouldn't say anything
hear firsthand account from the officers
who arrived to the alleged scene of
domestic violence plus a look inside
depp's l.a penthouse with police body
camera footage
johnny
is definitely not here and later did
witnesses see any injuries on amber
heard i just don't remember seeing any
mock bruises or anything
we are live in fairfax virginia to break
down the latest testimony law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Applause]
[Music]
everyone to law and crime daily i'm your
host brian buckmeyer jurors in the
johnny depp amber her defamation trial
get a look inside the couple's penthouse
on a critical date in the case that
glimpse is through police body camera
footage law on crime's angel levy is
here with the footage and the officer's
testimony
well brian there were actually two
police calls to the penthouse on the
evening of may 21st 2016. that is the
night that johnny depp went to the pet
house to collect some of his belongings
and to tell amber heard that the
marriage was over six days later amber
heard went to court claiming that johnny
depp had hit her in the face with an
iphone that night she appeared at the
courthouse with a mark on her face so
here's some body camera footage from the
second police call from that evening
[Music]
conversations
[Music]
okay
[Music]
johnny
is definitely not here
[Music]
[Music]
now the officers from the first police
call both of them testified that they
had not yet received body-worn cameras
the evening of this call so that second
set of officers those are the two who
had those body-worn cameras and all of
the officers their video depositions
videotaped depositions played today for
the jury and they discussed why they
didn't believe there was any evidence of
a crime and why they didn't fill out
police reports
did you see anything that you would say
was in disarray
i did
not that second protected sweep did you
see anything
that made you believe there had been a
crime committed
i did not so what did you determine this
call was after your investigation
a dispute
a verbal dispute
it's not against the law to argue i
argue in my life
so you decided that there was only a
verbal dispute therefore it didn't
constitute domestic violence from the
information or lack of information i was
able to receive from the witness and the
information my partner gathered yes uh
yeah i would need additional information
just because i see a female with pink
cheeks and pink eyes doesn't mean that
something happened
they should be sad and crying that their
dog died
now both of those officers said they did
not see any type of red mark or an
injury on amber heard's face or really
any other part of her body
they said that any redness they saw on
her face appeared to be from her crying
and they described the people with herd
along with her as being uncooperative
and officer signs one of the first
officers on the first call said that
they had no clue that this apartment
belonged to johnny depp when they
arrived brian
bill angela as you said we know the
police arrived days before her accused
depp of abuse but how does this incident
connect with the defamation case as a
whole
well if you think about it brian this is
where the whole thing this is where it
stems from like this is like the seed
from which this whole issue kind of
sprouts up out of the ground it starts
with may 21st and then the six days
later the may 27th claim of domestic
abuse with the courts that's when it
becomes public and then amber heard when
she writes that op-ed in 2018 she refers
to becoming a public figure two years
prior referring or representing domestic
abuse so she's referring to that so
while it may still be a high hurdle for
johnny depp to prove defamation this is
where it starts this is the starting
point for the 2018 op-ed because if she
had never done the tro or any of that
stuff it would never have been public
and she would never have been a public
figure representing domestic abuse makes
sense speaking of other litigation and
jeanette depp's libel case in the united
kingdom supposedly dismantled this
testimony from the officers that didn't
seem to happen here why do you think
that is well this was decided of course
by a judge in the uk and the system is
different there i actually spoke with a
reporter from the uk
today about the differences and the
judge there felt that they didn't do
their job that they didn't do their due
diligence and didn't
dig far enough so that question is
really going to be for the the jury to
answer here in the united states brian
all right stick with us internet we'll
be right back with you thank you still
ahead on law and crime daily our live
johnny depp amber heard trial coverage
continues
hear from a talent agent that
represented both depth and her does he
believe the washington post op-ed tanked
dep's career
[Music]
welcome back our johnny depp amber heard
coverage continues with testimony from a
talent agent who represented the couple
via video deposition christian carino
says he believed depp lost out on pirate
six because of herds accusations
do you believe that mr depp
is still a shroud of mystery not visible
to the public
and when did that change
i don't know exactly when
would you say it was cumulative over the
period of time as a result of all of the
litigation and the publicity ensuing
probably
is there any one specific litigation
that you believe most significantly
impacted
on mr depp's personal reputation no
longer being a shroud of mystery and not
visible to the public
my opinion is that amber's accusations
would have had the most dramatic impact
on
his off-screen
reputation
i'm not talking about
any
one specific
accusation
when you say amber's accusations
what do you mean by that
[Music]
i i mean the things that
she's accused johnny of doing
both
in
that had been made public
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney bernardo violina co-host terry
austin and law and crime correspondent
angina levy bernardo carino's testimony
really ties the alleged abuse to the
claim that debt loss because of the
op-ed do you think this witness made out
depp's 50 million dollar claim
so i was a bit disappointed brian in his
testimony because he seemed like he did
not want to be bothered he definitely
did not want to speak he did not want to
be questioned it was like he was just
like dusting or brushing us off in terms
of the questions that were being posed
to him despite this being a civil
lawsuit even though he had the most
powerful information that he could have
gave and that is providing damages in
this case especially given that he's
been a talent agent for so many years
he's been in a business for so many
years so he knows what can make or break
someone in this in this industry and he
knows that the
what amber heard had said was very
powerful in destroying his career in the
sense that people did not want to be
bothered with johnny depp and almost
blacklisted them because when a movie
wants to be filmed they want to hear
about the movie when they're marketing
and not about the actors private life
yeah now tara this was a video
deposition but both sides got to
question him in that video so how do you
think carino fared on cross-examination
was hers attorneys able to show there
was something else that damaged deb's
career
well i agree that christian carino was a
bit on the hesitant side but i do think
that he maintained his ground i do not
think that herd's team made a lot of
points what carino basically said is
that depp's reputation as an artist held
up but his personal reputation did not
and that personal reputation absolutely
hurt his professional it said basically
that he did not get pirate six because
of the fact that these accusations
harmed him and he was able to point
specifically to emails etc and texts
where he didn't get the job based on
that article so i think basically that
depp's team did a good job as far as
christian carino's
deposition was concerned yeah now and
jeanette that's what we're seeing from
behind the screens but you're there on
the ground so what's your tech takeaway
from wednesday's video deposition
you know i think there was a lot of
really interesting information in that
deposition you have to keep in mind
obviously this is about the defamation
but he had a lot more or the alleged
defamation he had a lot more to offer he
talked about amber heard wanting to
reconcile with johnny depp even after
she filed for that domestic relations
restraining order the domestic violence
restraining order she said that he she
he arranged that meeting in 2016 in san
francisco in the summer
and that she wanted to get back together
with depp and it sounds like johnny depp
did not want to get back together with
amber heard and she also claimed to be
filling time by dating elon musk and he
she had complained to him uh when the
relationship with elon musk ended that
you know she didn't like these things
being so public and carino said to her
well if you don't like your private life
being in the public quit dating famous
men absolutely well angela great
reporting on the ground as always thank
you very much coming up on law and crime
daily we take a closer look at an
alleged altercation between johnny depp
and amber hur
did hurt show signs of abuse hear video
testimony from the front desk worker at
los angeles penthouse when we come back
[Music]
welcome back we continue our coverage
now in the multi-million dollar
defamation suit of johnny depp versus
amber heard on wednesday jurors are
shown the video deposition of alejandra
romero the front desk manager of the
eastern columbia building he testified
how hurd appeared in the days following
an alleged domestic violence incident
i'm asking specifically i did not notice
any bruises cuts swelling red marks or
any other injuries of any kind to miss
bird's face who wrote it
that's what i said
i didn't sew any marks or bruises on her
face
that's what i said
they asked me
they asked me if i remember seeing
anything i said i just don't recall
seeing any marks or brothers because she
was just sitting in front of me
i just don't remember anything anything
just don't remember they put how it
would be so obvious like someone has
like
a black eye i would have like whoa you
know
i would have seen that and i would
remember because
it's something that you will all you
will see
you're like so noticeable like you will
all like you will remember but when i
was there talking to her she was like
three feet away from me she was right in
front of me i just don't remember seeing
any marx bruises or anything would it be
fair to say
that you cannot testify by one way or
the other whether ever heard was
domestically
abused by johnny depp on may 21 2016.
i can't i cannot say that i will stay
hot for not agreeing to testify against
anyone of domestic violence because i
was not there i didn't see anything i
didn't hear anything i was not there i
was never there i was probably hundreds
of miles away
and got no idea what happened that day
terry so far everyone who has testified
said they did not see herd's injuries do
you think there's a logical explanation
heard will give for why and what could
that be
well yes there are two logical
explanations the first one is that she's
going to try to say that the officers
who were involved didn't look carefully
and she's going to say that others like
alejandro romero who is now my favorite
witness just basically didn't see her at
the time of the incident as far as the
officers are concerned i think that they
absolutely
did a good look around they tried to
make sure she was protected they asked
questions they were not cooperating with
the police and so they didn't even file
a report as far as alejandro is
concerned he didn't want to be there
either he basically said look you
already asked me this i told you i was
right there i was in front of her i
looked at her in her eyes
she didn't have anything on her face why
are you asking me this i don't want to
be involved and i loved his sincerity
and i think the jury loved him as well
yeah bernardo maybe this is a little bit
of me playing devil's advocate but
domestic abuse often happens behind
closed doors away from the public eye so
how much credit should the jury give
these witnesses for not seeing the
aftermath of something that tends to
happen in private
so i think bryan it depends on the
witness and i say it depends on the
witness because a lot of these witnesses
that are being called are being called
to see if they corrupt they can
corroborate that there were injuries or
a lack of injuries afterwards because
obviously we know mr romero was not
inside of the house where both uh deb
and amber heard were living in and
actually when this happened if it
happened so none of these witnesses are
really being called in to testify about
that but to be able to say look after
something happened you don't know what
happened but did you see anything on the
person's face because that's what we
call corroboration especially when we're
dealing with he say she said it's like
what else can you bring in to
corroborate what's coming out of amber
heard's mouth but here we don't have it
and mr romero came off so credible i
think he was a great witness
unfortunately for those attorneys it was
not worth the squeeze absolutely thank
you for that and we are continuing to
follow the retrial of billy shamirmir
here at the law and crime network he's
the man officials say killed more than
18 elderly women in the dallas texas
area between 2016 and 2018. this trial
focuses on the death of lou harris
chamier mirror is accused of smothering
her with a pillow in order to steal her
jewelry and other valuables according to
authorities shamir muir would pose as a
maintenance or health care worker to
gain access to the victim's homes
officials say one woman chamir amir
allegedly attacked survived mary bartel
that incident led officials to the
defendant and they say it ultimately
helped connect him to harris's murder
jurors heard from bartel via video
deposition on monday on tuesday a dallas
police officer testified to discovering
harris's body and finding keys to her
house inside shamir mir's car when he
was arrested chemie amir's defense
previously argued that there is no
evidence that puts him at the scene of
the crime
when we come back the deadly rush
shooting months after alec baldwin fired
a gun on set body camera footage shows
the chilling moments after the incident
[Music]
welcome back newly released body camera
footage shows a scruffy alec baldwin
during his first interaction with
deputies after the shooting of helena
hutchins on his russ movie set in new
mexico last year hutchins the film's
cinematographer died after a prop gun
held by baldwin fired during rehearsals
on set in october there's been
contention surrounding the incident as
officials have not charged anyone
hutchins family filed a lawsuit against
baldwin who's an actor and producer of
the film and recently the state's osha
fined rus productions 137 000 for safety
violations on set this week the santa fe
sheriff's office released a slew of
investigative files including photos
videos and audio interviews alongside
the footage from several of officers
body camera footage the sheriff's office
released police interview footage
showing the moment police told baldwin
hutchins had died
no one presumed she was shot with a
bullet any projectile went through her
body that's no one even considered that
that was impossible
all i knew was the gun went off she hit
the floor he hit the floor he started
screaming he's in a loud name she went
into shock when she went down i thought
what was stuck we all said the same
thing what was stuck in the barrel
with something left they didn't clean
the barrel i mean literally i'm holding
the gun
and let me slowly slowly pull turn cop
down as soon as i copy the bang i do
have some very unfortunate news to tell
you
she didn't make it
[Music]
so joel's still at the hospital
but
the
other person involved didn't make it
as a former homicide prosecutor you must
have seen countless people react to
finding out they have killed someone
what are you looking for to gauge
whether baldur's reaction is authentic
and do you think it is
so usually you want to gauge first off
you want to get some background
information as to what happened so here
in looking at alec baldwin i believe
that his reaction was genuine and
genuine because he didn't believe nor
did anyone else believe that the gun was
loaded with an actual live projectile so
i saw his reaction to be genuine it's a
different case every time but in this
case he was genuine yeah now terry do
you think baldwin's reaction in the new
video footage will change the outcome of
any civil or potential criminal
litigation
you know while i think it shows us that
he is being genuine bernard is correct
about that and that it was a horrible
event and it's something that i think
everybody regrets i don't think it's
going to change the result of any of the
civil litigation and i don't think it's
going to change the result of the
criminal litigation you know he's being
sued and the producers are being sued
for negligence and i think to determine
whether he's negligent or not they're
going to have to determine whether or
not what was going on on that set was
reasonable the wrongful death action
same issue negligence was there
negligence on that set has nothing to do
with how alec might have reacted to what
occurred and i don't think it's going to
affect criminal charges either
interesting to see how it plays out
definitely be used in an argument in
some way shape or form thank you both
and thank you for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you